you're under the influence get out so as
you know the Golden Globes are kind of
the party warship right I think so yeah
they're little looser than stin a few
other plays yet so we're just having a
fun little sobriety test to see which
stars are globin on the implements are
you down
I don't know I'm terrible at tests since
I left school a long time ago but I was
right so what I want you to do is stand
kind of cover 1 foot and I'm going to
count to 10 by Emma Stone's oh I can't
even do it on two for you but I have
these pretty big Gucci shoes that's
right between us the camera can't see it
one mo soon one of us she re messed up
sir you went in the stone for when a
myth j-51 emma stone 6 whenever stone 7
whenever stone a tatum stone 9 m 7/10
and emma stone and the stone oh wow okay
alright way she's that she is the
coolest gal I never had a chance to me
lovely next one a finger to nose test
alright okay so stand feet together
hands by your side
and I'll say left or right and you'll
just use your index finger to touch
yours
here we go alright so left right left
Ryan Reynolds oh there you go Ryan
Gosling Oh Ryan Gosling where's Ryan
Reynolds Wow
I got you I did a dozen finger to nose
tests all right so I'm gonna say
nailed it you're sober you're sober I
think you need a shot
take this it's kettle one you need a
cooler man I know they're a little warm
very warm
all right everyone seems really sober so
I'm just gonna start handing out free
shots it's all free shot from buzzfeed
Julie Chen do you want a free shot from
buzzfeed
yes Julie chin once a viola free shot
[Music]
Ryan free shot from buzzfeed free shot
from Busby
want some vodka Chris fine free shot
from BuzzFeed Matt thanks Lauren
Chris free shot from BuzzFeed free shot
from BuzzFeed
he wanted it
I'll just stay good
[Music]
you
[Music]